the russians have been trying to take
lissa chance for weeks
signs of the back and forth in this
battle are everywhere
population a hundred thousand once
but just a fraction are now left
and among them makola one of a small
team of medics under fire every day
just as we're talking you can hear the
distant booms this is a town that is
effectively encircled
by the russians
solutions
they're places which surround this town
and cremina fell to the russians
overnight
they almost lost a colleague a few days
ago
she went to buy bread her friend tells
me and the shelling started she lost a
leg
there is just one ukrainian held road in
and out of blizzard chance now
fortified as best it can be the russians
are 20 miles to the north
20 miles to the south and just a few
miles to the east
if they capture this place they will
unite their units from the north with
those from the south the strategic
russian gain would be huge
depopulating the east is part of the
strategy too and it's working everywhere
along this part of the donbass there are
convoys heading west
chinese
one town west of lesser chance
where we found igor his wife marina and
their little boy artem
it's the first time he's been out since
they escaped perpassna three weeks ago
is miles east but it is a front line
that at last for now feels far away
is
watched
the people who have streamed across
ukraine across europe they are from
places like papasna bachmat
and in the central square a group of
families who've just got out
there
foreign
it's grim one story after another
the wife who buried her husband outside
their apartment
the mother who's missing her son
and the sisters who say goodbye as one
stays behind to search for her husband
mark stone sky news in eastern ukraine